c'est le nouvel album de justin bieber
est dedans ils racontent toutes ces
histoires qu'il a eu avec selena gomez
ah oui c'est moi si vous voyez un mec
parler à une personne dans le wave ii
c'est normal c'est touche pas à mon
poste et l'hypnotiseur on vous dit pas
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe apparemment
il ya quelqu'un qui voilà ce qu'on va
encore avoir des articles capucines à
l'avs
voilà quelqu'un du par l'oreille l'homme
qui murmurait à l'oreille à la voilà
c'est donc cyril lui
tous savent à quel staff est là
les staffs et n'a rien j'avais fait une
mise à jour cette petite mise à jour
rien de bien grave bien entendu merci et
alors c'est reparti la société risette
contre la le support du progrès je peux
apprendre qu est ce qu elles veulent pas
roulé ma pomme allez-y mais elle croit
que c'est pas apparemment la fin à la
faim oui c'est voulu dire quand même ce
que c'est un oui un pommeau nantais
voulait la pomme c'est un peu ça la
gênait vous étiez pas prêt à manger je
pense que décidément fait attention aux
pépins cola n'est pas là j'ai un peu
faim mais c'est pas une pomme si c'est
une femme c span pops et cinq femmes
donnez-lui qu'ils vénèrent ça lui donne
la pomme oui j'ai un petit peu faim si
vous la mangez pas est-ce que je peux
toujours sous windows que pour 17
qu'avait excusez nous voulait tomber la
tour d'émotion
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'atelier une banale et je dis c'est pas
saisonniers s'est mise à jour apple
ah bah oui 5 fruits et légumes 1,5 et
bien et bon les pink c'est lui qui va
être déçu ce soir
ces footeux et plus c'est bon non mais
quand même à fabriquer ce qu'elle va
être malades n'ont été arrêté non pas
trois mois je n'ai pas gagné moi ça ici
non mais ça suffit
non conservé c'est bon mammuth à être
abandonné à oui mais j'ai peut-être car
je souhaitais jusqu'à trois mondes allez
je vais prendre ce serait totalement
réveillé mais en vous réveillant vous
constaterez qu'elle jouait dans la
bouche mais en même temps vous verrez
que justin bieber et empêche de vous
dans un costume foncé avec une belle
chemise bleue 1 2 3 et vous rêvez
d'aller lui faire un bisou c'est ce que
vous avez mangé dans la bouche
on était tous secondes
[Rires]
[Musique]
italian open chaise par l'état bien
alors si oui où
maintenant vous parler italien
maintenant est ce qu'elle peut pas le
faire après la pub ça va être contente
de voir justin bieber mais c'est mon
rêve my dreams is to sing voulait rater
vous pouvez nous sentîmes choses
ensemble et austin bieber juste après la
pub est de 1 franchement avec justin
ah ouais avec justin si vous nous
rejoignez merci merci merci mes chéris
capucine ma chérie ça va bien ça va plus
il est persuadé
vous êtes avec justin bieber oui et on a
fait trouver une chanson qu'on a pu mais
il m'a dit qu'il chantait que français
le remettre dans l'ambiance et qu'il
avait récupéré votre portefeuille oui
j'aimerais justin bieber parce que je
vous explique si vous nous rejoignez
elle et voilà c'est du leader pour la
personne puisque une personne le pdl
mettez un synthé mettaient quelque chose
bougeait plus en régie merci donc on
voulait qu'on écoute une chanson de
justin bieber 1
adagio ce qu est ce qui pouvait la
refaire un peu pour capucine what do you
mean nommé je me contrefous de cette
chanson je pouvais pas le faire juste
pour capucine mais je ne connais pas
cette dame j'ai jamais entendue même je
n'écoute pas la même radio j'écoute
[Applaudissements]
voilà la remettre oui ne pas nous la
faire au moins deux secondes pour
recapitaliser ses affaires un cri
d'alarmé pour l'armée
boiteux nous est très douloureux mais
allez-y faites là what do you want to
[Applaudissements]
know you mean you to you mot division
commis même il est beau ah ouais et
ingrate surtout enfin prend un peu de
poil au menton qui n'agit pas très bien
rasé elle allait perdre et que cette
hausse timber qui dit série merci d'être
avec nous assistons café le tf 1 la pro
donc jamais j'adore j'adore mon chéri
donc non je vais la rébellion serait
plus simple non non non ok opale rallye
donc maintenant aux capucines à 3
simplement j'ai claqué des doigts et là
vous pourrez donc présenté ses fans tout
ce magnifique album de justin bieber
mais la manière de pierre bellemare
tenter les achats 1 2 3 je peux faire la
promo oui raison du nouvel album de
justin bieber c'est le nouvel album de
justin bieber est dedans ils racontent
toutes ces histoires qu'il a eu avec
selena gomez
ah oui mais de manière très très
personnel et très très très belle donc
je pense vraiment vous pouvez aller
l'acheter parce que va six cartouches
ans bravo merci
cette excellente publicité ça fait
plaisir
selena gomez et vous avez des nouvelles
commandes s'est pas les jeux selena
gomez avait des nouvelles
ces deux accords n'a pas du tout fait
tout nous-mêmes à nantes ou que c'est
mort de che marmaille cria longtemps
longtemps elle avait 12 ans ouais c'est
fait vous avez cassé avec ses comédiens
je n'ai pas cassé mais si vous voulez
être ici
ça c'est délicat était mignonne
ah oui oui bon dos bon dos santé très
très bien les chaussettes
celle qui l'a quitté ares 1 à vous
connaissez ma vie privée très gênant et
tombe sur l'émission mais la pierre
bellemare il a poussé les nageurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]